going back to you guys's Point why
because I'm only 23 so I'm kind of torn
between whether I would want to continue
working after I have kids from your
opinion like why would you feel like
women working is something that they
shouldn't do it's not that you should or
shouldn't it's just ideally no if you're
with the right man then you wouldn't
have to work if you want to you can but
I would rather that you raise the kids
yeah who's who's gonna be watching the
kids when you're at work some babysitter
and so then you have a stranger
influencing your kid more than you are
and you have to look at it as a place of
trust and love he picked you he he
trusts you and picked you over every
woman in the world put his children in
you and instill that trust in you to
take care of them while he's away making
sure the family is taken care of is
there a more important duty